anti-nuclear activist Helen Caldicott is
the founder of physicians for Social
Responsibility and a Nobel Peace Prize
nominee her latest work the new nuclear
danger lays out the Bush
administration's connection to the
nuclear weapons industry she argues that
the merger of weapons firms in the 1980s
created a powerful lobbying tool with
undue influence on foreign policy and
the use of military force the program
runs just over an hour okay
our first speaker tonight is my boss
Alexandra Lee is the founder and
executive director of project laundry
list he graduated from Vermont Law
School in May of 2001 has worked for the
Vermont Secretary of State on political
redistricting and has written
extensively on capital punishment his
works have been published in the
northern forest forum and the Catholic
Worker he has previously served on the
board of directors for the peace and
justice center auto Creek Audubon
Society the advisory board of free the
planet and the public policy advisory
board of the Vermont Association of
nonprofit organizations Alex currently
lives in concord new hampshire where he
is special assistant to the
commissioners at the Public Utilities
Commission ladies and gentlemen please
join me in welcoming alexander lee
I don't think I've ever been introduced
before but uh um it's great to have you
all here good evening um good evening
all right good i just want to make sure
you're all their the lights are kind of
bright i am so excited that Helen
Caldicott is here with us this evening
and I'm not going to be up here for very
long I just wanted to talk about the
first time that he met dr. callicott I
was a student here in Vermont and I
invited her to speak to at a piece
symposium that we had organized down at
middlebury college and she showed up and
she said if we all hung out our clothes
we could shut down the nuclear industry
and with that idea we ran ahead and
started this group called Project
laundry list which is the sponsor of
this talk this evening and we've been
encouraging people since 1995 to hang
out their clothes to save energy and
there's plenty of information out front
a new book about clotheslines that
accomplishes all my dreams and focus is
on clothes line art and and ways to save
energy so if you're interested at the
end of the talk will be in the back and
now I want to introduce well I actually
have an announcement to make to the
Vermont coalition against Star Wars is
planning actions around upcoming events
as such as the May seventeenth for Bush
Putin summit and the june twelfth and
thirteenth 20th anniversary of the
freeze movement in New York City rally
and any new ABM treaty withdrawal
attempts the next planning meeting will
be May second at 7pm to be some justice
center so if you can make it that would
be great and that's very much on point
with this evenings talk this evening
speaker really one of my heroes Helen
Caldicott comes from Australia she's
nearing the end of a four-week tour and
then she's been talking about her new
book but this is not her first book and
money of you I'm sure are familiar
with her books nuclear madness if you
love this planet and her wonderful
autobiography a desperate passion Helen
Caldicott was nominated for the Nobel
Prize by Linus Pauling's and she's also
the founder of an organization
physicians for Social Responsibility
that founded she founded that
organization and that was nominated for
the Nobel Prize and and won the Nobel
Prize she's currently involved with a
number of different projects she is a
medical doctor and and that's really
what gives her her expertise on the
medical effects of nuclear power she's
worked with children and been in and out
of the medical profession throughout her
career as an activist and speaker and
author and she's currently the president
and the founder of the nuclear policy
research institute which has just opened
a new office in california and so
without further ado let us welcome a
woman who needs no introduction dr.
Helen Caldicott
well thank you very much and I first
want to thank the excellent singer who
really expresses everything that's
happening today with such passion and
Verve I want to thank Alex Lee for
organizing this event and Aaron who
worked so hard on it tonight is a pretty
special event I wrote this book two
years ago before george bush was elected
i started it and then I continued as
George Bush was not elected and and then
I had to write a postscript after
September 11th so it's been a sort of
quite a journey it was rejected by the
original publisher simon & schuster
after a couple of weeks because the
paragraphs weren't just right or some it
was clearly clearly rejected like
michael moore's book because it was too
hot politically so wonderful press
called the new press took it off and
published it the new nuclear danger it
was originally called George Bush's
military-industrial psychosis and it's
tragic consequences and
and it had actually a marvelous covered
had George standing it was a very police
look on his face slightly confused
smiling looking up beside him was Cheney
looking very pleased with himself a
novice it was power and behind them was
a huge mushroom cloud well I was told by
some of the people who did the blurbs on
the cover that if I kept that cover I
would totally lose my credibility and
the good thing about me is that I have
credibility so although I was in love
with the cover the cover was removed and
we've got this rather dour grim cover
which actually is appropriate for today
the book covers the fact that I want to
say one other thing that Jim is a
carpenter Jim heard me talk and he
started all the town meetings that led
to the nuclear weapons freeze and helped
her in the Cold War appropriately he's a
carpenter as was another great person in
history so Jim I honor you but tonight
we've got to do it again folks because
the Cold War's over and the hot was
really on and what we didn't realize
when the Cold War ended and the Berlin
Wall came down was the weapons were not
removed and they still there exactly the
same as they were in the 80s even though
Russia's our best friend fusion was the
first to come and help America when the
terrorists attacked but each country
still have two and a half thousand
nuclear weapons on hair-trigger alert
and how did that happen well we got a
president who is fairly gormless called
Clinton and he didn't go to Vietnam and
he smoke some dope didn't inhale don't
believe it and he didn't have the
courage to take on the Pentagon here he
set up Liz Aspen to run the Nuclear
Posture review and unless said former
senator we don't need weapons on either
side we must abolish them it's stupid
but less died so young man called ashton
carter came in to run the Nuclear
Posture review and he was no match for
the Joint Chiefs of Staff who are truly
slits if any of you have ever worked in
a place like Harvard Medical School or a
big corporation you'll know that he goes
climb on egos and people the top can be
really ruthless the Joint Chiefs are and
they destroyed ashton carter and they
called ash to the carpet they said and
at the end the weapons still stayed in
place nothing changed Clinton never even
went near the Nuclear Posture of you and
at the end one general said if you
threaten our missiles and our early
warning system he said baby that's
threatening the family jewels and I want
you to take that comment on really
seriously you all know what the family
jewels are don't you I don't have to
explain the anoj meet the family jewels
that comment is very significant because
it's not the number of bombs and ration
it's the psyche of the men's minds who
run this country at the moment that is
the passat pathology and the less in
medicine we work out the cause of a
disease we can't cure it the cause is
called the etiology so the etiology of
the problem in the world today from a
nuclear perspective is the pathology
without in those men psyches and that
comment demonstrates really clearly the
pathology that's why I call one of my
books missile envy which apparently the
generals absolutely hated their language
is very sexual and I won't go into it
now but they speak about their missiles
in very sexual ways like missile
erectors and softly downs and deep
penetrations and the like with
absolutely lack of any embarrassment
before a general audience including
women's so the pathology is actually
quite deep so what happened after that
was that Clinton didn't even really
supervise this at all and during the
process lesben and others and Cheney
before him found out about PSYOP the
single integrated operational plan as
America and the nuclear weapons lab
produced more and more and more and more
and more and more weapons 77,000
hydrogen bombs during the nuclear age
when 1,000 bursting on a
cities could cause nuclear winter and
the end of life on honors 77 times the
number of bombs necessary to destroy the
planet junior officers were sort of set
up to work out where to target the bombs
and it was sort of like pin the tail on
the donkey will do this one here in this
one there it was totally random no one's
seen you from any administration during
the nuclear age took any control of this
at all in fact at one time there were 60
hydrogen bombs targeted on Moscow alone
60 every single thing was targeted shoe
factories anything the enemy held most
dear and as one of these people said I
don't care what the enemy holds most
dear we must hold that particular thing
at risk he said I don't care if the
enemy values grandma's if the enemy
values grandma's that's what we target
and I was deeply offended when i read
that because i'm a grandma i mean the
sort of thinking that these people
engage in is really really pathological
and before I go any further I now must
describe so you have a baseline from
where I'm coming from the medical
effects of nuclear war and I want you to
know that Russia has two and a half
thousand bombs ready to go they take
half an hour to get here their early
warning system is so decayed it only
operates eight hours a day which makes
them very jumpy america's got two and a
half thousand ready to go we were on the
highest state of alert on September 11th
DEFCON two before George got to press
his button from DEFCON 5 4 3 2 press I
don't know how long we stayed on the
highest state of alert but I would think
several weeks we were 10 seconds from a
nuclear war in 85 95 when Norway
launched an American missile and old
missile with a weather satellite on
board Moscow picked up the telemetry and
as America's policy still today is to
fight and win a nuclear war again
russia still and the way you do that is
you knock their early warning satellite
up their eyes and ears you knock out the
control system in Moscow and you launch
your Trident missiles and I won't go
into all of us now your MX missiles with
10 hydrogen bombs and the Minutemen 3
actually I will just show you this this
is called America's nuclear Heartland
and if you fly over the Midwest you can
see the missile silos that's North
Dakota absolutely measles with missile
sites North Dakota South Dakota Montana
all over the Midwest these missiles are
ready to go to men in the missile silos
each armed with a pistol one to shoot
the other if one shows signs of deviant
behavior and they were ready to launch
so the way you win the nuclear Wars you
launch your missiles in secret and you
land right on top of the Russian missile
silos because you got very accurate
missiles now and you kill their missiles
millions of people dying is called
collateral damage by the Pentagon if you
miss a few of them myself your new
national missile defense which will
never work is going to mop up a few of
the missiles which get lawn gets
launched and you've won the nuclear war
the fact that it will create nuclear
winter is not acknowledged by the
Pentagon because they don't know what to
do about that data so they turn their
backs on it and ignore it now as Moscow
saw this missile going up they naturally
assumed America was going to fight and
win a nuclear war they picked up the
radio waves from the missile and said my
god were under attack that loop takes 15
minutes satellite down to Moscow then
Yeltsin had three minutes and so would
Bush to decide whether or not to press
the button so he wouldn't lose his
missiles and lose the nuclear war so the
first for the first time in the history
of the nuclear age he opened the
football the nuclear codes to press the
button he had generals standing over his
shoulder he was in a hardened alcoholic
I may tell you that's why he's not in
power now probably had worked Wernicke's
encephalopathy and Korsakoff syndrome
from alcohol
and the generals were saying press that
button three minutes at the last 10
seconds the missile veered off course
and they closed the football so we were
10 seconds for annihilation of course
their weapons are targeted here and
every single university town with a
population 10,000 or more is so targeted
that was in the New York Times but near
the abit trees towards the back page so
those sort of things occur not
infrequently every year in both early
warning systems so the fact we're still
here to me is a miracle and the fact
that those weapons are still on
hair-trigger alert is the elephant in
the living room which no one talks about
yeah we're talking about the Middle East
and Palestinians and the Israelis and
the whole thing we're talking about what
Bush is up to the new nuclear posture
review but the elephant stands there and
none of the press is covering the issue
that that's the foundation upon which we
have to look at the World Trade Towers
attacks at the Middle East at india and
pakistan facing each other off with
nuclear weapons and these nuclear
cowboyz in the White House I don't know
even if Bush understands this certainly
dan Rather didn't last you when they
took him to the missile silos he had no
idea that they were still there ready to
go if he doesn't know do you think Peter
Jennings does he might Tom Brokaw if
they don't know nobody knows now say the
button was pressed in Moscow 10 minutes
ago and we don't have on NPR to hear oh
we are under a nuclear attack please go
to the nearest fallout shelter that's
probably one under this building and
it's going to come in there for in 20
minutes at 20 times the speed of sound
we won't hear it it will land on this
beautiful building would explode with
the heat inside the Sun and dig a hole
three-quarters of a mile wide and 800
feet deep turning the university of
vermont and us and the earth below to
radioactive fallout
shot up in the mushroom cloud five miles
in all directions from here the
epicenter everybody will be vaporized
because at those temperatures even the
skeleton turns to gas there was a little
boy in Hiroshima reaching up to catch a
red dragonfly in his hand against the
blue sky and there was a blinding flash
nor what he left behind him was his
shadow on the pavement which is in the
hiroshima museum and that was a very
small bomb 20 miles in all directions
everyone will be dreadfully burnt
everyone will die a burn patient is the
most difficult we ever treat hundreds of
units of blood fresh frozen plasma skin
transplants and the like and often after
a year we still lose these patients the
White House however has been stockpiling
large quantities of morphia just in
cases a nuclear war we don't know where
it is will be similarly dead or injured
and our hospitals will be destroyed if
you look at the flash and you're not
vaporized your eyes will actually melt
and run down your cheeks as they did in
Hiroshima then the whole area will be
consumed in a fast on the 3,000 square
miles and winds at 500 miles an hour
extraordinary winds will suck people out
of windows and turn them into missiles
traveling at 100 miles an hour windows
popcorn into shards of glass
decapitating people and as the fire
storms rage they will use up the oxygen
in the fallout shelters as they didn't
dress than the firebombing and you'll be
asphyxiated everything's targeted in
this country everything but if you did
survive in a fallout shelter way out in
the country you can't come out for six
months because the fallout will be so
intensely radioactive within days you
find your hair was falling out and you'd
vomit and bleed to death like in on the
beach the book i first read which turned
me on and branded my soul and I lived in
Melbourne they say they'll use the old
people as food gatherers because we
won't live long enough to get our
cancers incubation time of cancers five
to sixty years
there'll be millions of corpses and as a
decay lots of cows in Vermont cut dogs
cats humans as they decay the bacteria
mutate in the radioactive environment to
become more virulent and our immune
makers mechanisms are depleted so
they'll be epidemics of diseases we now
control like typhoid plague dysentery
you name it but it will be the end of
the world because as the cities burn
huge clouds of toxic black radioactive
smoke will rise up to the stratosphere
and cloud the earth with a cloud so I
think it will block out the Sun for up
to a year and cause nuclear winter maybe
the cockroaches the algae and the like
and may survive so that will be the end
of Brahms Alto Rhapsody that will be the
end of Beethoven's ninth that will be
the end of Shakespeare's sonnets shall I
compare thee to a summers day thou art
more lovely and more temperate rough
winds do shake the Darling Buds of May
and summers lease hath all too short a
date that will be the end not just of a
species about 20 million other species
that have at the planet with us that
will be the end of possibly the only
life in the universe and it could happen
tonight and the only reason the Russians
have got their weapons in places because
this country hasn't gotten rid of hers
and Clinton had an opportunity to get an
Air Force One and fly to Boris and say
Boris sign here and he would have done
anything now we've really got nuclear
cowboyz in the White House I have never
seen an administration so dangerous in
my life I think Bush doesn't really
understand what's going on too much he
hasn't read many books he's virtually
never traveled and he's a figurehead on
the prow of the ship of state the
president is Cheney who lives
underground at the moment in the fallout
shelter there's a huge fallout shelter
near Washington where the Congress go
interestingly it's got a hospital but
the Congress people aren't allowed to
take their wives only their secretaries
so I always have a good look at the
secretaries when I go in and lobbying
Congress I suppose Lynne Cheney might be
done there or might go with him and then
there's Rumsfeld Secretary of Defense
who Kissinger describes as the most
ruthless man he's ever known including
global potentates Rumsfeld lies
consistently but is very charming so the
press don't know how to handle him and
they sort of giggle in an embarrassed
way but he consistently lies and when I
saw him on Jim Lehrer a year ago that
I've got to get on debate you because
you're lying it's inappropriate to lie
to the American people in such a grave
situation and then there are other
characters in the Pentagon called
Wolfowitz who is going to go into Iraq
by hook or crook and kill thousands of
civilians and then there's a man called
Richard Poole when Cheney said we are
going to keep fighting wars the next 20
years and we've got 60 countries we can
attack it's wonderful for Lockheed
Martin Boeing trw and Raytheon to steal
your money my money and war is endless
and Richard Perle has called the Prince
of Darkness by his colleagues in the
Pentagon said and I'll paraphrase it we
will keep fighting wars for decades and
one day our children will sing songs in
our praise Power has no power there's
been a ruthless nuclear battle within
the administration Powell has been
marginalized he's a token the State
Department full of really excellent
intelligent sagacious people has been
marginalized the Pentagon run the
foreign policy now of the United States
which is totally inappropriate and so
does Lockheed Martin which helps to run
the Pentagon so that's the the basis
from which I speak as a physician and I
only look at the planet I'm going to
talk politics to you and the like but as
a doctor I have to know why and how
things are happening otherwise I can't
treat you so we're going to look at the
politics and the dynamics of this
administration and what they're up to so
that we can make the diagnosis and I say
to people as i read grey's anatomy and i
learned every word really boring this
nerve passes anterior and lateral to the
ureter I had to learn
to become a doctor I know the
internationally of the hand so that if
anything happened I could probably I'm
not a vascular surgeon but I could
probably handle it quite well if there
was a disaster now we are all the
physicians to a planet that is in the
intensive care unit being run by people
who are not physicians i would say
imposters and this is the new greys
anatomy and to understand how to save
the planet we all have to read this and
learn it now those other are other
excellence books too and works which and
that this is very heavily referenced I
got most of this in the New York Times
now what else is going on you know the
nuclear weapons labs Lawrence Livermore
Los Alamos and Sandia they designed the
nuclear weapons now they should be
closed down because the car wars over
and America has no enemies does it wool
but what about North Korea whoo full of
starving people who they might build a
nuclear weapon soon or they might launch
a missile they launched a missile crazy
one that crashed in the Sea of Japan
they wanted to put a weather satellite
up but Rumsfeld said North Korea's a
rogue state but what about Iran whoa
they're moving more and more in a
moderate direction it's not appropriate
therefore to antagonize Iran because the
fundamentalist might come back into
power Iraq when the weapons inspectors
left at some few years ago there were no
more weapons they said Scott Ritter who
has one of the inspector said there were
no more now has they might have been
working on a few weapons I don't know
but almost certainly doesn't have
nuclear weapons this is a case of
clinical paranoia the axis of evil North
Korea Iran and Iraq great speech for
Bush to give it's like you're sitting
next to a man in the bus and you know
for sure with no objective evidence that
that man has a gun in his pocket that's
the definition of clinical paranoia
there are zealots who attacked the world
trade tower towers and the Pentagon
there are zealots in this country too
the Republican Party has been captured
by quotes right wing quotes Christians
who are not I don't think a Christians
bootlace but they believe in Armageddon
they believed in Revelations that the
world will come to an end of one third
of man was a mark of God on they've
already gone amok rise up and meet Jesus
in the sky and they paid painting use of
people in their pajamas and their
nightgowns rising up to meet Jesus and
the rest of us will burn in hell Reagan
believed that he said yes I think the
end times are coming weinberger believed
it Secretary of Defense and James Watt
Secretary of Interior used to pray on
his office floor every morning for
Armageddon to come there are people
within this administration i would
suggest probably Ashcroft who believe
that too so they think it's a good thing
and they would not work necessarily to
prevent it I would call them absolute
zealots and totally inappropriate to be
running the Republican Party and they
have it by the neck so America doesn't
have any enemies and what America should
be doing is moving to work with the
family of man or all nations with
humility to produce peacekeeping
operations in the world not preparing to
kill and more killing and more killing
now I want to go back to the labs who
are involved at this point in making
more and more nuclear weapons why for
Clinton to get the scientists to go
along with the non-proliferation treaty
he had to bribe them the scientists have
a mystique in Congress because i've
captured the energy inside the stars so
he said look we'll let you have the
second manhattan project which was the
biggest scientific project ever in the
history of the human race which made
three bombs the first one was called
Trinity after the Father Son and Holy
Ghost and if that bomb hadn't exploded
as planned the telegrams the president
was to read it's a girl it read it's a
boy the second was exploded over
Hiroshima and killed 120,000 people like
that and the third over Nagasaki which
killed about 80,000 little tiny
firecrackers of bombs
but now they've got a second Manhattan
Project spending more money than they
spent during the Manhattan Project
they're studying a hydro dynamics of
plutonium which is but tonian becomes
fluid just before it reaches critical
mass and it's all very fascinating
they're doing sub critical testing
underneath the desert floor as I speak
in Nevada so they're violating the
letter and the law of the Comprehensive
Test Ban Treaty right now and they're
going to build more than 80 nuclear
weapons a year they're working on a pure
fusion weapon that can't be verified
from space which ends arms control not
that arms control isn't being ended
right now by Bush and so in the language
they use is fascinating when a man
designs a bomb he sleeps with the
mechanism that makes a bomb explode in
the desert the night before the bomb
explodes he sleeps with the bomb he
sleeps with death he describes giving
birth to a bomb he describes labor pains
before the bomb explodes and he talks
about postnatal depression this is the
language used by the scientists in the
labs they are actually sleeping with
annihilation sleeping with mass genocide
and so that's another pathology that
needs to be examined and in my book i
quote a man called gusterson who's an
anthropologists who studied the labs and
the scientists quite complex stuff what
the labs are up to they have to be
closed down then there's a Pentagon and
I describe how the Pentagon works and
how Lockheed Martin which is the biggest
weapons contractor now in the world
occupies various places in this
administration Lin Chinese wife I mean
Chinese wife Lynn sat on the board of
Lockheed Martin for 20 years Stephen
Hadley wrote the foreign policy for the
Republicans at the convention he's from
Lockheed Martin and I've named there is
people apart from that the Heritage
Foundation really decided who would be
in this administration hands up those
who know who or what the Heritage
Foundation is if you've got a note
foundation runs this country it's funded
by hertz rent-a-car Holiday Inns Coors
beer Ocean Spray cranberries Reader's
Digest Hertz rent-a-car and Lockheed
Martin amongst others Lockheed Martin
people sit on its board if you ever turn
on Jim Lehrer there's usually someone
from the Heritage Foundation there they
call themselves a think tank they're not
a think tank they're an advertising
agency for the corporations and as that
was described in that wonderful song
this country is not free anymore and
it's being run totally by corporations
as went Enron so goes Lockheed Martin
now Heritage Foundation is ubiquitous
it's on every TV show they write op-ed
pieces they write infotainment for the
news they Lobby and write the laws for
Congress they wrote the mandate for
presidency for Reagan's first term and
they wrote mandate for presidency for
his second term and he enacted them all
they're doing the same thing with this
one and they don't believe in big
government at all no health care no
education don't fix the bridges no
alternative energy no mass transit pass
they believe in socialism for the
Pentagon and the corporations and so
they're spending now nearly half a
trillion dollars a year on death and I
say that advisedly because an an admiral
once said to me Helen our mandate in the
Pentagon is to destroy property and to
kill people just took my breath away as
a physician now if you spent a thousand
dollars a minute since Jesus was born
you would have just about spent a
trillion dollars half a trillion dollars
a year on death and Bush wants to spend
three point five trillion dollars in the
next few years on weapons and you don't
have any free medical care inerts your
country and how come you allow this to
happen if that happened in Australia
would be a revolution you're one of the
only countries in the Western world with
no free medical care and when I mean
free i mean free i go to the doctor i
pay the doctor and I go next door with a
bill and the money in cash is put in my
hand by my government because it's my
money and my government represents me
the corporations are creeping in a bit
that's why we need to do something in
Australia at the moment but it's serious
here 40 new two million people was no
health insurance who died in the parking
lots of hospitals and diabetic coma and
it's funny because when I talk about
some people say oh free medical care
that's socialism all nasty word but what
was Jesus what was Buddha huh it's more
difficult for a rich man to enter the
kingdom of heaven than a camel to pass
through the eye of a needle period Jesus
was in the capitalist he was a socialist
he was a Christian no he wasn't a
Christian he was a Jew who worked to
stop the zealous from attacking roams
the Rome wouldn't destroy the Jewish
race it's sort of appropriate now
actually in this point in history and
you know you don't have free education
it costs thirty thousand to educate a
kid at at an Ivy League college I went
to medical school totally free for six
years got an excellent education that
was my too so you've got to take your
country back from the corporation's
you've got a corporate presidency
without a doubt and you know that and
you know that the Congress is run by
corporations they're all corporate
prostitutes except for some good ones
like probably well lay might have taken
some money from corporations Jeffords
might but he's a nobleman on the whole
and then the cynthia mckinney barbara
Lee Dennis Kucinich but you can name
them on you know two hands and I just
well I've got a great quote in here and
two great quotes actually if you'll just
allow me to find the page I'm sorry fact
look it up like it's 24 year there's a
wonderful man called Harold Lasswell who
is a leading American scholar of
propaganda in 1939 and listen to this if
the mass will be free of the chains of
iron it must obey the chains of silver
if it will not love honor and obey it
must must not expect to escape seduction
and that's what the Madison Avenue
psychologists do via TV and so
propaganda seduce and brainwash like
Pavlovian dogs the American population
and most populations in the world now
and this is from Abraham Lincoln 1864 I
see in the near future a crisis
approaching that unnerves me and causes
me to tremble for the sake of my country
corporations have been enthroned and an
era of corruption in high places will
follow and the money power of the
country will endeavor to prolong its
reign by working upon the prejudices of
the people until all wealth is
aggregated in a few hands and the
Republic is destroyed what a man he was
probably your greatest president okay so
i won't go into the corporation's power
in and the like except that the Heritage
Foundation runs this country and it
actually runs the world cuz it helped to
set up get WTO trips taps and the whole
thing globalization level playing fields
free trade all of those euphemistic
terms have used by corporations which is
only so corporations can rule the world
and people are getting you know in
Argentinian our people can't even draw
money out of the bank's because there's
no money to draw because WTO and get
they advised Argentina to move to the
dollar from I think the peso they the
the bakery shops are empty people are
going to be starving like next week in
Argentina and that's the result of the
Heritage Foundation's philosophy then I
move on to star wars five layers of Star
Wars theater missile defense and then
the fight for three layers the boost
phase the transit phase in the terminal
phase none of which will work best to
hit a missile with 10 bombs on it in the
booze phase 10 seconds as it goes
through the atmosphere each bomb
contains 10 pounds of plutonium one
pound hypothetically can kid give
everyone on earth lung cancer
hypothetically so you spray a hundred
pounds of plutonium all over the land
but it's good because that you get 10
bombs in one shot
will be no time for human intervention
so it will have to be operated by battle
management computer which Carl Sagan
told me can never be tested and can only
be used in battle then as the missile
drops off and the bus continues through
space with its passengers Pentagon
language and the passengers are dropped
off at various points you've got ten
targets to hit and you can put mylar
balloons up there which confuse the hit
to kill vehicle all the tests so far
have been forged and I won't go into
that it's in the book and then so so
it's total confusion it will never work
so three days ago general Kaddish in
charge of the US Space Command said well
what we're actually going to do is have
nuclear-tipped and I like the wood
tipped missiles and we're going to put a
nuclear-tipped missile with maybe a ten
Megaton bomb so you blow the bomber and
you get all the bombs to the hurtling
through space and the mylar balloons and
it's very efficient except you get a
surge of electromagnetic pulse coming
down which could paralyze the whole of
the United States and melt every single
wiring system that's another thing the
Pentagon don't want to talk about
further turn their backs on it and I
knew they had nuclear weapons in their
back pocket and the fifth stage of
national missile defense or Star Wars is
the militarization of space run by the
US Space Command which is a favorite of
Rumsfeld it's now become Army Navy Air
Force Marines and US Space Command and
they're going to militarize space with
nuclear power plants to run the laser
beam weapons particle beam weapons
orbiting hydrogen bombs so an America's
going to dominate space although
ninety-six percent of the world's people
do not live in America and we don't like
that and this isn't the greatest country
on Earth what about Australia
well we've got kangaroos and koalas and
you know we don't tend to fly flags too
much we'd rather lie on the beach and
drink beer and we're a bit of dissolute
society but we're not bad but it's a
good country you know what about India
you know what about China with its
ancient ancient culture and it's the
beginning of the end when a country said
I'm the greatest on earth it's like my
grandson he says I'm the boss of this
house Mickey does he's 10 you know he's
sort of out of it anyway I'm down in the
southern hemisphere and I say to Mikhail
my grandson look Mickey there's the
Southern Cross oh there's an orbiting
hydrogen bomb can you imagine how we
feel and one of your general said make
no mistake about it it's not politically
popular now but we're going to fight war
in space and from space down to earth
and take our cities and effect very many
kills like vaporized cities in a flash
of light that's what's going on and you
don't read much about it it is in the
new york times but you have to glean it
to find it space is a global Commons
belonging to all of us and it's totally
inappropriate that the United States be
doing this you know I just want to
describe um I know that politicians
fairly well you know I spent an hour and
a quarter with Reagan and the White
House in 1983 I met his daughter in the
Playboy Mansion there is such a place in
Hollywood and he and patty came up and
said I want you to meet my father I
think you can change his mind about
nuclear weapons so he we met him at the
end of his working day which was four
o'clock and we spared in the black limo
into the southern portico and he came
into the downstairs library in which
there were no books and he didn't know
where to sit sighs I showed him where to
sit I said you sit there and I'll sit
here and I said you probably don't know
who I am do you and he said yes you're
an Australian you read on on the beach
when you're a young girl and you're
scared of nuclear weapons and I said
that's right and he said I term scared
of nuclear weapons but our ways to
prevent nuclear war differ I
I'm scared of nuclear war but I ways to
prevent it differ I believe in building
more bombs so we were off to a flying
start um every single thing he said was
inaccurate he didn't know anything about
data statistics numbers of bombs CIA
reports technology so he'd say something
and I'd correct him and he got quite
uptight so I'd take his hand and I spend
at least half that hour and a quarter
holding his hand and reassuring him he
got a piece of paper out of his pocket
and read to me that people who work for
the nuclear weapons freeze which was
eighty percent of the american people at
that time are either KGB jupe's or
Soviet agents and I said that's from
last month's Reader's Digest and he said
no it's from my intelligence files which
patty told me was one in the same thing
um as a physician I had to assess his IQ
you have to with patience you have to
know if mrs. Brown will put the
suppository in at six a.m. in the
morning can you rely on her and take her
digoxin before lunch and I estimated
clinically his IQ to be about a hundred
nice old man but totally inappropriate
to be President I believe this one isn't
quite as intelligent now I say that and
it sounds funny but it's so serious it's
so serious and the people at the high
name is so dangerous now that just put
out a new nuclear posture review to say
America's going to use nuclear weapons
anywhere it likes the original policy
was only to use them against nuclear
nations but now I guarantee when's when
they go into Iraq they may try out their
new bunker buster half the size of the
Hiroshima bomb so the firewall between
conventional and nuclear weapons is
being breached one nuclear weapon used
in the Middle East could trigger the
early warning system which is so fragile
of Russia and America and then it's all
over if they go or when they go into
Iraq her saying could use scuds against
Israel Israel has intimated she'll use
nuclear weapons back Israel's got two
hundred nuclear weapons she's the third
largest nuclear nation and the
world that's never mentioned either is
it she's a country with weapons of mass
destruction as is Britain and chuck
France and China but this country has
the most weapons of mass destruction and
it says no one else is to have them but
you see everyone emulates America so if
America's got the largest nuclear
stockpile it's working as I speak on
camera on biological weapons and
mutating bacteria to become more lethal
huge stockpiles of chemical weapons well
everyone says well if they're doing it
we will so what has to happen in this
world of today and what does America
have to do what should have happened
after September 11th mi5 mi6 Mossad KGB
NSA CIA FBI should have got together in
an intelligent fashion and found those
terrorists quietly and subliminally and
brought them to the International Court
of Justice and try them like they tried
the Nazis they are international
criminals but did gone
to go and bomb a country that had
nothing to do with it because see the
Taliban were armed and trained by
America to fight the Soviet Union
they're a product of america and the
al-qaeda an offshoot of that the
terrorists came 15 of them came from
saudi arabia and four from egypt how did
saudi arabia celebrate new year's day
they beheaded three gay guys in a square
watched by hundreds of thousands of
people but authority arabia there in LA
you know in iraq war iraq was armed by
America to her sane as the CIA product
armed and trained by the CIA in America
to fight Iran but in Afghanistan one of
the poorest countries on earth with 7.5
million people on the verge of
starvation heavily land mind America
went in and tried its new weapons like
Hitler did in Spain which induced the
painting of gernika by Picasso and he
never went back what did they use men
young men drop bombs on Afghanistan from
40,000 feet in the air and landed back
at base did they smell a blood did they
see the babies with their heads blown
off did they see men walking around with
the intestines hanging out like in the
First World War in the Second World War
this isn't war this is electronic
cyberspace genocide what else do they
use cluster bombs a cluster bomb has 240
bomblets each bomb lot is the size and
shape of a coke can painted yellow
thirty percent don't explode on contact
and become landmines then America
dropped food parcels our size and shape
of coke cans painted yellow and children
run up to pick up the food parcels and
get their heads blown off and those
yellow things are dying all over
Afghanistan and they're still probably
using them and then they use thermobaric
bombs near nuclear weapons five kilotons
the size of the bombs they're going to
use to but bus bunkers nuclear weapons
they send out a sort of an aerosol which
explodes and there's such an enormous
negative pressure it sucks people's
eyeballs out of their sockets and
rupture
lungs and they probably use depleted
uranium weapons they use them in Iraq
uranium has a half-life of 4.5 billion
years they used up to 800 tons and when
the weapon hits the tank it burns
producing tiny particles that can be
breathed into the lung that's a
radioactive area for the rest of time
the incidence of childhood cancers gone
up six to 12 times and my colleagues
can't treat their children because of
the sanctions they have no drugs and
women are too scared to give birth
because they're giving birth to monsters
Cyclops's single eyes and then carefully
no brain no vault the skull but the baby
breathe sucks and cries for a week and
then dies the incidence of those
malformations has doubled and will be so
for the rest of time they use them in
Kosovo and probably use them in
Afghanistan this isn't war this is
genocide and that's what's going to
happen in Iraq and they can't wait to
get in there what does the Bible say
thou shalt not kill what did Jesus say
he said love thine enemy do good to
those who hate you only if we try and do
that we can call ourselves Christians if
we don't were not period and what does
American need to do now needs to develop
humility like Thomas Merton did when he
walked into a cathedral and had a
conversion and scrubbed the floors and
trappist monastery for a year and didn't
talk to anyone America needs to get rid
of the Pentagon it needs to move its
military expertise to the United Nations
and work with the family of Nations in
peacekeeping operations all over the
world it needs to redistribute the
wealth so two-thirds of the world's
children are not starving and
malnourished it needs to feed and
educate all the women so the population
grows drops and it's not right the
twenty percent of the world's population
including mine only
percent of the world's wealth and vice
versa this new increase in the Pentagon
budget 48 billion would feed all the
children of the world and all american
needs for protection is the Coast Guard
Canada to the north alive the Pentagon's
writing about the fact that Canada might
invade and Mexico the other thing
America's doing right now setting China
up as a new Cold War enemy and ringing
her with bases in Uzbekistan Afghanistan
tajikistan Georgia South Korea's being
armed Taiwan's being armed Japan's being
encouraged to violate its peaceful
Constitution and my country contains
many bases that are part of this dog
water system you see the rest of the
world is are enablers to America's
nuclear addiction and if you have a
father who's an alcoholic you say come
on dad you're sick i'm going to take you
to a drying-out center you need some
help and I don't see any leaders of the
world doing that at the moment there's
no courage they're scared of trade
sanctions I suppose there's no need to
be scared of this country none I wish I
was Prime Minister Australia the New
Zealand is the only ones that stood up
to America and they said we refuse to
sit in the dress circle of the nuclear
theater you're not bringing us your
ships in any more to us and they became
really noble hero heroes they've got a
woman Prime Minister and I suppose I
should say to that fifty three percent
of the Earth's population are women are
full of estrogen and progesterone which
has a different psychologically like
psychological impact than the other
hormone and Frances just passed the
parity bill so that fifty percent of all
people running for office have to be
women and I think that's totally
appropriate in today's world absolutely
in fact it should be it should be
mandated the num of the magic numbers
thirty percent below sleep sent
representation the women vote for
missiles to please the men and above
thirty percent they say no you're not
having you missiles anymore we're voting
for milk for children and it has nothing
to do with politics it's a different
sort of dynamic and the two working do
you gave the work will but one
king alone doesn't work well at all and
we can see that because the world is on
the verge of extinction so we have a
great challenge before us and i'm
setting up an institute called the
nuclear policy research institute the
forms are at the back I'm going to take
on the Heritage Foundation and I'm going
to get a major
I'm going to get a major media person to
place me and the best experts in the
country to challenge and debate with
Rumsfeld Cheney and to be proactive and
teach the American people a truth as we
did in the 80s we had the second
American Revolution in the 80s when i
started in 78 most people said better
red than dead good to have a nucleon we
said well do you know what happens if
the bomb drops on burlington and people
said no and we described it nice if my
god this is bad for our health and the
businessmen said it's going to be bad
for business and the architect said it's
going to be bad for the monuments and
then the morticians asked me to their
annual meeting and said will you talk to
us and I said why they said we don't
want to invite bomb radioactive bodies
and I said don't worry you'll be one
yourself but that you can remember the
Catholic Bishops rotor pastor later they
need Redemption right now they can write
another pastor letter the Methodist
bishops wrote a pastor letter you
remember and at the end of five years
eighty percent of Americans opposed
nuclear weapons and we ended the Cold
War with Gorbachev that was the second
American Revolution peaceful intelligent
sagacious and dignified and know what
we're going to do it again and so we're
going to mobilize mobilize the majority
of Americans again via the media and
produce a mass movement through the
treetops level and in five years we're
going to end the nuclear age we're going
to produce abolition of nuclear weapons
with Russia and the other nuclear
nations say they will abide by that and
do the same thing and we're going to
close down all the hundred and look
three nuclear reactors in America in
five years then I'm going to go home and
have a rest
so that's my prescription for survival
all of you who are here belonged I'm
sure to various groups still do doctors
lawyers merchants Chiefs educators and
you have to get your organization's
going again and we have to take back
this country this country needs a third
revolution we end the nuclear age and by
doing that we free up the country the
money to be used for the benefit of the
American people so there are no homeless
in the streets no one's unemployed in
the richest country on Earth and
everyone's cared for and this free
medical care the whole thing it's so
easy so simple and the American people
are such good people and this is your
destiny you came to this country from
all over the world and the reason you
came is to save the planet and I know
you can and i'll help you and the rest
of the world will then truly love you
and you will take your place in the
annals of history thank
so you see it's really exciting and we
can all get get off antidepressants and
be really excited so maybe I don't know
how much more time there is but i'll
take some questions
did art drop on you
please tell us what you know about half
project military installation and less
of that blast the ionosphere with
high-frequency sound waves well it is
going in and Alaska harp H AARP and I
didn't write about it in the book but it
will severely apparently disrupt the
weather conditions it's to be used to
disturb the ionosphere so it can
interrupt the quotes enemy's
communications through the atmosphere I
need to read more about it they're also
blasting the oceans with Sona waves that
so loud it destroys or disturbs the wet
the whales and the Dolphins and all the
other fish I mean what they're doing is
obscene and there's no reason to do it
anyway even if there was there are no
enemies and and it's sort of this little
boy fascination I think with seeing what
we can do with nature the last nuclear
war was over 50 years ago why don't they
happen more often well if they happen
more often no one would be here would
they often people say to me the right
wing say well you know its nuclear
weapons that kept the peace we we built
nuclear weapons to stop nuclear war to
keep the peace and I don't know how
we're still here but I remember when I
was a young intern an old man aged 85
came in he said I've been driving for 60
years and I have never had an accident
but tonight he broke his neck so the
logic is amin so we need to be rational
human beings and understand what's going
on but we need to have courage to take
over the world and i think it's
important to speak the truth loudly and
clearly never need approval be different
have the courage to go through your
grief in your pain after hearing this
tonight feel the depression don't take
antidepressants and through the
depression you will grow psychologically
and I'll give you an example a woman
heard me talk 20 years ago same talk bit
different she got so depressed she
couldn't move virtually for two years
you know when you get really depressed
and your joints ache and you can hardly
move
she woke up one day bang she knew what
to do she didn't work it out she got on
the best clothes dockings pearls and
went to the heritage foundation she
knocked on their door they said hello
who are you she said I'm Joan they said
hello John they gave her a job well paid
for a year so when they went home at
night she stayed and went through all
their records and found out what their
policies were for strike nuclear war
winnable nuclear war who funded them and
at the end of the year she said thank
you very much and she set off on a
crusade across America telling Americans
and their churches and synagogues what
the heritage foundation was up to now
that's one example i could give you of
hundreds or thousands and there are
people in this audience now what needs
to happen is Jim might might not feel
like it a gym I feel like it again but
we need to start the town meetings in
Vermont and New England once again we
need to take on the Bush administration
full frontal we need to teach the people
in New England about this and guess what
you'll lead the revolution like you did
before that's why I'm thrilled to be
here in Vermont you are fine noble
really strong people okay couple of
other questions do you take that
seriously ah Jose bastani director
organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons was forced out by the
US robert watson UN panel for climate
change removed by the US US ambassador
refuses to attend Comprehensive Test Ban
Treaty meeting in Vienna please comment
what can I say I have never known
America to behave like this before
they're bandits I mean I said they're
anarchists but someone corrected me and
said they're not really but I have never
known any administration to violate
almost every international law including
the anti-ballistic missile treaty the
cornerstone of all other arms control
treaties how dare America behave like
this who do these people think they are
they've got to be removed from office
and don't forget the Democrats are not
much better
as gore Vidal says America's got one
political party with two right wings
take that seriously you've got to take
your country back the Democrats except
for a few exceptions notable exceptions
are not much better please speak about
the penetrator bomb now being developed
that has a nuclear warhead in its
midsection purpose is to destroy
underground bunker busters I think it's
made of depleted uranium which is 1.7
times more dense than lead so it
penetrates the earth then it's got a
nuclear warhead which is a five kiloton
bomb half the size of the Hiroshima bomb
and it's probably be used on her saenz
bunkers it's a ridiculous thing and it's
a nuclear weapon so America's moving
into practical nuclear warfare if you
haven't yet would you please tell us a
bit about the foundation you plans to on
starting yeah new people NPR I will be
based in the Bay Area affiliated with
Mills College and apart from getting on
TV all over the country and putting it
very best people in America up there we
will hold symposia on various subjects
like redoing nuclear winter and what has
global warming done to the data of
nuclear winter what will laser beam
weapons shot from the space into the
atmosphere due to our climate change in
our atmosphere how could they trigger a
nuclear war what is the National
Ignition facility at Lawrence Livermore
labs which is developing pure fusion
weapons who's involved which
corporations which Pentagon people which
Congress people and Senators what does
the administration have to do with it
and so a lot of us stuff I don't
understand either and I'm going to get
Bill Clinton to chair the symposia I'm
not going to pay him either he's going
to do it as a service
and I'm gonna get George Shultz to come
and you know people from the Harvard
Medical School I'm going to get people
from Lockheed Martin to come and talk
very credible but it will be an
exploration of the subjects and we'll
write books about it articles and go on
television and we'll bring the top
journalists like Matthew world and and
William broad and and dan Rather and the
rest to educate them because education
is the key who said it Jefferson and
informed democracy will behave in a
responsible fashion and that's always
been my experience workers at Vermont
Yankee you're worried about losing their
jobs that the plant closes what can you
say to them is their health safety at
risk Vermont Yankee is a filthy plant
these workers are being exposed every
day both to internal images which they
inhale or ingest which lodge in various
organs radiating a few cells they're
very carcinogenic they are being exposed
to gamma radiation throughout their
whole body including their testicles and
the sperm contain the genes for all
future generations no one should work at
a nuclear power plant and it should be
closed down why doesn't Vermont lead the
country in the development of solar
power now I know you have cold winters
but you have a lot of Sun and in New
England we could still power most houses
using Sun and here's another crazy
thought to Australian scientists worked
out that two cows excrete enough methane
from their gut to power and fuel and
heat a single house for a year you've
got lots of cows here I haven't got any
money yet for this I need a million
dollars a year for five years and I
guarantee we'll be able to do it the
money is not forthcoming its peanuts
compared to what many people have and do
you know what I occurred to me yesterday
we should be being paid by the
government to save the world they should
be funding this institute not spending
money on killing the world
so we need a grant from the government
five million peanuts and we'll take on
the Pentagon all bottle Helen Caldicott
is the founder of physicians for Social
Responsibility and a Nobel Peace Prize
nominee she's the author of nuclear
madness missile Envy if you love this
planet and a desperate passion and
autobiography her latest is the new
nuclear danger